Let's go next to our caller from the two to
four area code.
Who's calling today from two to four.
Hey, it was me.
Yes it is.
Okay.
Hey David.
I was talking to my friends about foreign
policy, especially in regards to Iran and
how the Trump and configurations can save
a rattling pretty much their entire time and
Bolton being gone a bit of a reassurance,
but with this fiasco, with the oil fields
and Saudi Arabia and they're placing us troops
to guard those oil fields, almost like bait.
Yeah.
It seems like we're continuing to build up
now.
I'd heard that if since war with Iran is such
an unpopular idea, the Trump administration
is actually waiting until after reelection.
Do you think that's possible?
That's totally possible.
It's also possible that Donald Trump, I mean,
Trump doesn't always listen to advice.
He may say, Oh, well, a war will help me win
reelection in 2020 so we shouldn't underestimate
the possibility that he would escalate sooner
as a result of that.
But yeah, I mean, I, I, you know, initially
when people saw Bolton leaving who were saying,
Oh, now there's no chance of a war with Iran.
No, no, no.
There, it could be under different circumstances.
It could be motivated in different ways, but
I don't think that threat of war with Iran
is gone now that John Bolton has gone.
I completely agree with you.
Yeah.
All right.
Thank you.
Okay, thanks.
I appreciate it.
It sounded like he was on speaker, but it
was good enough.
I figured I wouldn't interrupt with that.